good morning believe nation happy
Thursday hope you guys are doing well it
is nine o'clock eastern time it's time
for gratitude journal live stream number
29 to begin super excited to be here
with you guys today how this works we
all share three things that we are
grateful for for you guys watching live
leave it in the chat on the side you
guys watching out towards they leave it
below it's important it's a daily
activity just like brushing your teeth
just like washing your face just like
reading and exercising and working out
it's a workout for your mind to you know
ya feel uncomfortable and feel unhappy
with where you are because you want more
because you want to make a bigger impact
but also being super happy with what you
do have and recognizing it if you guys
are watching this stream you probably
have a lot more than most people in the
world the second component to it is that
that you actually feel it that as you
read it you think about it just for a
few seconds to feel the real benefit of
it um and you can do everything with me
here we are so I'm ready to start mine
up um what should I go with today I'm
going to go with one the Toronto Blue
Jays the hat is not on today there it is
so we lost last night pretty badly I
just a lot of does a lot of negativity
right now in the Toronto media and the
fan base here seen you know what we
should have done to do better and all
this stuff and really I'm just grateful
for an awesome season you know we've had
20 something years apart from last year
of nothing you know no postseason and
here we are in the playoffs we did we
got to the final floor we did what most
teams didn't and I'm just grateful for
the buzz that I gave the city and the
fun that I had following along and that
was all free for me right so just super
grateful for the Toronto Blue Jays and
the awesome season that we did have
number two I'm bit before the people i
have around me that I can ask for
feedback
there's a couple changes i'm thinking
i'm making stay tuned next week we'll
see we'll see what happens i have a
meeting kind of mid next week and it's
awesome people have these people to
bounce ideas off of get their input get
their feedback i'm a mix of you know i
do the thing it's it's hardened head
right like i do the things that my heart
wants to do and then and in my head
helps me figure out how to go and do it
so so i'm using my head to get feedback
from people and how to better execute an
idea that i have so we'll see I'm super
grateful for all the people that I have
that I can connect with and number 3 i'm
grateful that the tyrese top 10 video
finally came out man this video if you
guys haven't seen it it came out last
night it's it's over an hour long this
is the most i have personally ever
invested into making a top 10 usually
it's my team do doing all the research
and i just watch the clips and approve
it and we get to put together but this
one I jumped in on um I just felt that
it could be better and I put my own
little personal touch on it so it was
too almost two full days of my time
working on this means i couldn't do
other stuff which was super frustrating
but I'm also really excited that I got
up and that people are liking it leaving
comments and it's having an impact it's
worth watching there's a lot of great
comments in there i didn't know Tyrese
Gibson you know I didn't know that side
of him so I'm uh it was awesome to see
and it feels it feels really good that
it's up and that you know when you work
so hard on something and then you see it
come to life it feels good and so I'm
grateful for that let's get to you guys
what do you guys capable forward to some
shoutouts we've got six minutes what do
we have marvel what's up believe nation
grateful for anything today kicking us
off I love it maravillas grateful for
the chances and the opportunities for
the conditions in my life which helped
me hashtag improve myself every day I
like that gr is thankful for the rain
that cleanses the city
and revitalizes plants yeah it's raining
today in tirana cloudy outside great
book from my home which shelters me from
the rain I like that for flowing health
wealth and love through the lives to the
lives of all around me I love that
Louisville I'm back will miss some of
the gratitude streams in the future
since i'm going to pick up my mom from
work it's 3pm here when the stream
starts that's okay man we appreciate you
when you are here if not then when you
pick up your mom getting from your phone
and you can both join the gratitude
livestream together I want the first son
mother gratitude livestream journal
experience to happen here so let's
figure out a way to make that work with
the bill all right keep going Xena
what's up welcome Saint Dane be high hey
Dan welcome aboard Zeno is grateful for
shine who always leaves nice and
encouraging replies in your channel yeah
thank you for that uh you know i'm going
to send that to her I'm sure she's gonna
really appreciate that she really is a
good job ash she responds to people and
a super nice way that I necessarily
wouldn't always been dealing with haters
but yeah she does a great job so thank
you for recognizing that to yesterday's
basketball practice I had some physical
problems the last couple weeks but I'm
happy I can play again I can still shoot
a bit i love that Zeno Danby is with J
reyez I love the rain all right Xena
where's number three Dana number three I
don't see it I don't see it oh there it
is electricity we've moved past the body
part of the day he's into electricity
for a lot of things for allowing me to
connect with you guys to cook and store
food to see at night there's a lot
certainly to electricity does give us a
lot what else what else what do we got
what do you guys give before sky's the
limit great rising everyone I love that
man and green 441 universal spiritual
laws that keep me grounded and aware in
life number two health number three
nature I love it what else what else
what else Danby
II I'm grateful for imagination they
make so many things possible and invites
us to reach for those possibilities
awesome thanks for sharing Dan once you
guys got oh my chat froze there we go
there we go there we go wow so many
comments oh holy cow what do we got up
up up up up above great examples
beautiful people I agree sky's the limit
any league of legends experiments today
we'll see well it's up to jail you'll
see what happens reaches in the house
good morning believe nation couple of I
love it cement good morning welcome
aboard Kelly morning believe nation
super grateful for my daughter's sense
of humor this morning I love that my
home it's my sanctuary and Cleveland
Indians Kelly you had to rub it in
Cleveland Indians world series baby
Kelly had to rub it in Kelly moving on
Jay yeah I'm grateful I'm on time
welcome j k l BN good morning everyone
I'm grateful for the cold front coming
in to the Caribbean it's so funny it's
so funny how we want the other thing
right like when we're in the cold
environment and want the key when you're
a hot environment you want the cold you
know when you're Brown here you want
blonde hair and vice versa you're
straight here you want curly hair you
know so interesting Christina hey I'm
cleaning my garden we're all clean the
garden of our minds today right now what
else the vons top 1% of the one percent
all right Adam good morning Joseph I'm
grateful for the time to meditate this
morning very cool prabu people for our
dr to chandler coming out within an hour
what's our dr feel like i should know
this guys let me know with our DRS uh
shish Sher Khan she sure can't good
morning or hi good evening good evening
welcome aboard Melissa good morning
people christina is that a bottle
machine is doing emojis nakuru hi people
for life taking it a day at a time I
love it Hasani I feel strange I just
want to be happy imagine the feeling
happy wasn't strange that's a special
place
basic Goryeo doesn't matter I don't
that's been reference to all right Caleb
en I'm grateful for my coffee maker
greca because I can make my coffee on
the stove which is great when the lights
go out very cool to as a nose earlier
point i hope the lights are not going
out on you too much Lindsay grateful for
those who challenge us every day to
become the best versions of ourselves a
hundred percent totally agree with you
Lindsay Joseph beautiful morning je je
I'm good for my friends supporters and
loved ones love that Sarah people for
water beautiful for the invention of
napkins I love you guys good puppy the
invention of napkins gratefully the
amazing invention of cellphones double !
i love that joseph is grateful for a
very restful night and that's awesome
guys it's nine ten thank you so much for
joining me I'm gonna hop on to the
League of Legends livestream answer your
business questions there are no other
live streams today I'm going to be out
most of the day in appointments and
meetings so no this is it it feels weird
not having Thursday live streams will
move you back on um next week so join us
on twitch and if I don't see you there
then hope you have an amazing day go and
crush today continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you soon